when a beloved actor dies millions of
people who didn't even know them grieve
in their own way but for their co-stars
showing up to work without the person
you've been acting alongside for years
is tragic
he rose to prominence while starring as
finn on the musical sitcom glee but in
2013 corey monteith passed away after
battling with addiction since his
teenage years the entire cast struggled
to deal with the loss especially his
co-star leah michelle whom he had been
dating at the time of his death
michelle said that eventually not acting
was more painful than getting back in
front of the camera
she wanted to be surrounded by the glee
cast again after all she and monty both
thought of the rest of the cast and crew
as family plus she said that month would
not have wanted her to give up on her
passion michelle explained on the ellen
degeneres show at the end of that year
there is an empowerment that comes with
grief at some point you find it it's
very hard but you will find it and i
think at a certain point you can choose
to sort of fall from this or you can
choose to rise and that's what i'm just
trying to do my best for him because i
know that that's what he would have
michelle still keeps monty's memory
close be arthur and betty white worked
together on the hilarious nbc sitcom the
golden girls which featured a group of
over 50 women living together and
finding humor in their old age there
were always rumors of a feud simmering
between arthur and white but their
co-star rue mcclenahan insisted that at
the end of the day their supposed feud
really came down to artistic differences
mcclanahan explained
bee came from a new york stage point of
view she always had what we call the
fourth wall and betty came from a
television point of view she would flirt
with the audience and pull up her skirt
and say hi sailor but b never
acknowledged the audience
when arthur passed away in 2009 white
was as heartbroken as any die-hard
golden girls fan after her death white
said i knew it would hurt i just didn't
know it would hurt this much
yes arthur and white would butt heads
behind the scenes occasionally but
underneath it all these two actresses
had great respect for each other and
arthur was greatly missed
when disney channel star cameron boyce
passed away after a fatal seizure it was
a harrowing wake-up call for his
co-stars
boyce died young he was only 20 and he
should have had an amazing life and
career ahead of him his descendants
co-stars couldn't believe that he was
gone dove cameron who played maul and
considered boyce a close friend said
that his death reminded the cast just
how precious life is in the wake of his
passing the descendants cast members
were going out of their way to spend
more time together cameron told e news
he just was everything that everybody
says he is he he was um
from
someplace else cameron also got a tattoo
to remember boys she chose a design with
a flower coming out of a gun
an international symbol for peace and
anti-war movements she stated that boyce
was working with an organization against
gun violence before his death and she
wanted to memorialize him as someone who
cared deeply about peace
as luke skywalker and princess leia mark
hamill and carrie fisher inspired a
generation of sci-fi fans who fell in
love with their star wars characters
when the franchise was revived with the
force awakens in 2015 legions of fans
were thrilled to see them return to
their roles and bring the story to life
for a new generation of fans but when
fisher passed away in december 2016
hamill's view on the films changed
there's no doubt that hamel loved fisher
and he cherished their friendship for
life however her death affected his
memories of star wars and he didn't have
much motivation to return for future
films hamill told abc news in 2018
rather than being sorry that
we can't have more of her i'm just
grateful that we had the time with her
that we did of course fischer did appear
in the rise of skywalker via archive
footage and hamel made one last cameo as
luke's force ghost bringing the
skywalker saga to a close after 42 years
john ritter played kaylee cuoco's father
on the sitcom eight simple rules for
dating my teenage daughter and while
they weren't actually related he still
felt like a father figure to her
his untimely death due to complications
with a heart condition left her feeling
lost and today she still thinks about
him all the time cuoco couldn't believe
that ritter was gone and the cast
addressed his death in a touching
episode of eight simple rules cuoco
continued moving forward in her acting
career landing a major role as penny on
the big bang theory but she never forgot
about her wonderful experiences of
working with ritter on the 15th
anniversary of his death in 2018 she
revealed that there isn't a day that
goes by when her memories with ritter
don't make her laugh at the same time
she still mourns his loss her big bang
theory co-star jim parsons said i don't
think she ever talks about him without
tears in her eyes she's emotionally
stable but there was definitely a
fatherly bond
when fans of riverdale and beverly hills
90210 got the news that actor luke perry
had passed away after having a stroke
they were devastated and his former
co-star shannon doherty took the loss on
a deeply personal level doherty had
worked with perry on beverly hills 90210
where the pair played long-time love
interests although the original show had
ended years before doherty was still
devastated by perry's death
he had supported her through thick and
thin and stood by her side when she was
fighting cancer
when the 90210 reboot was announced
doherty originally did not plan on going
back she did not think that the show
really needed her but when she got the
news about perry's passing she had a new
perspective she decided that she would
return for the reboot after all and it
would be the perfect way to keep his
memory alive the actress revealed when
luke passed away things drastically
changed for me and i felt like it was a
great opportunity to honor him and i'm
really glad i made that decision because
now i get to sit up here with a lot of
people that i respect and love
sadly actress debbie reynolds passed
away only one day after the death of her
daughter carrie fisher fans of both
women couldn't believe the news and
debra messing who played reynold's
daughter grace on the sitcom will and
grace knew that her life would never be
the same from the moment messing met
reynolds she was struck by her bold
presence messing told entertainment
weekly
debbie was really indescribable she
would come on stage and she was abroad
in the greatest sense she always was
entertaining and singing and dancing and
she was running off and doing a
one-woman show you know 300 days of the
year it was just crazy messing always
looked up to reynolds and she knew that
they couldn't let new episodes of the
will and grace revival go by without
taking the time to honor reynolds the
writers created an episode about grace
wanting her father to hold on to her
childhood home rather than selling it
because she didn't want to lose those
memories of her mother now she still
posts occasional tributes to reynolds
it's clear that she will never forget
the time they spent together on set
alan rickman was known for many
different roles but millions of people
knew him best as severus snape in the
harry potter films when he passed away
in early 2016 fans of the series were
heartbroken he brought this character
from the books to life and he played the
sinister role so well that it was hard
to believe he was such a kind and funny
man when the camera wasn't rolling just
take it from daniel radcliffe who grew
up playing harry potter alongside
rickman radcliffe explained in a
statement after the actor's death as an
actor he was one of the first of the
adults on potter to treat me like a peer
rather than a child
working with him at such a formative age
was incredibly important and i will
carry the lessons he taught me for the
rest of my life and career radcliffe
said that rickman has always supported
him whether he was working on a movie or
a play and that he wouldn't be the actor
he is today without rickman's guidance
when paul walker died in a car accident
his fast and furious co-star vin diesel
lost a best friend after walker's death
diesel visited walker's mom her house
was his first stop after hearing the
news
diesel shared on facebook his mother
hugged me and said i am so sorry i said
sorry you're the mother who lost a son
she said yes but you lost your other
half while filming furious 7 diesel
admitted that shooting the barbecue
scene at the end of the film was very
emotional in fact he had to step away
for a few moments because he just
couldn't believe that walker wasn't
there on set with the rest of the cast
diesel told usa today
i had never done a barbecue scene
without him and i just cracked and broke
down and had to walk off set to collect
myself
that was the only time i wasn't strong
enough to keep it together but the
entire cast and crew wanted to make sure
that they paid homage to walker
throughout the film finishing production
with the help of the actors brothers and
ending the story with a touching tribute
to the departed comrade
harold ramis and bill murray were an
unstoppable comedy duo they worked
together on films like ghostbusters and
stripes and it seemed like everything
they touched turned to gold
sadly the pair had a serious falling out
while working together on groundhog day
they didn't speak for over two decades
after
sometimes in interviews remus would
admit that he missed their friendship
and that he hoped they could be friends
again one day for the longest time it
looked like they would never reconcile
but when murray found out that ramus was
on his deathbed everything changed his
brother convinced him that he had to go
visit remus marie listened and the two
finally made up upon his death murray
reminisced on their many achievements
together murray said harold ramus and i
together did the national lampoon show
off broadway meatballs stripes
caddyshack ghostbusters and groundhog
day he earned his keep on this planet
god bless him
superhero films haven't always earned
glowing critical reviews particularly in
a pre-2008 world but christopher nolan's
batman begins sequel the dark knight was
an exception
heath ledger played the joker to
christian bale's batman and although
both actors were lauded for their
performances ledger's take on the joker
truly stood out
bale had a great respect for ledger's
talent he was truly a gifted actor and
that was perhaps never more evident than
it was in christopher nolan's
game-changing epic when ledger died
several months before the release of the
film bale was shattered he told parade
he was somebody who'd i'd been seeing on
a daily basis for months it takes a long
time to accept that someone's gone when
all body and mind are telling you that
this is somebody you will know for a
great deal of time
he was something of a kindred spirit to
myself bale was disgusted by the way the
media covered ledger's death and he
hoped that people could move past it and
view his work on the dark knight as a
celebration of his life
it seems like bale's wish came true it
came as a surprise to no one when ledger
posthumously won an oscar for the role
[Music]
tv might be all about enjoying a little
bit of escapism but sometimes the real
world gets in the way and there's no
more shocking an example of this than
when a beloved actor dies forcing a show
to say goodbye to the character they
played
miguel ferreira was part of an
accomplished show business family he was
the son of oscar-winning actor jose
ferreira and 50s pop singer rosemary
clooney as well as a cousin of superstar
george clooney a prolific actor he
joined the cast of cbs's ncis los
angeles in 2012 to play owen granger
assistant director of the ncis and
overseer of the office of special
projects in the la branch ostensibly
arriving to hunt down a killer he's
really there to keep an eye on the
show's regular squad and bring his
experience as a cia officer to the team
in a 2016 episode a.d granger tells his
colleagues that he's dying from a form
of cancer possibly related to exposure
to agent orange during his time carrying
out government missions in southeast
asia granger later disappears
disappearing from his hospital bed and
presumably dying from terminal cancer
off-screen by the time granger's
storyline was wrapped in 2017 ferrer had
died too like his character ferrer had
been suffering from cancer and passed
away the same year at the age of 61.
after a few years plying his trade as
film actor john ritter returned to
television in 2002's eight simple rules
for dating my teenage daughter and tv
has always been good to him he won an
emmy for his work on three's company and
he starred for three years on the 90s
cbs rom-com hearts of fire in eight
simple rules ritter played befuddled
family man paul hennessy who's deeply
anxious about his kids aging into
rebellious independent teens ritter had
only filmed one full season of the abc
sitcom when he fell ill on set in
september 2003 complaining of nausea
weakness and chest pain later that day
54 year old ritter had died of an
undiagnosed heart ailment called an
aortic dissection
after a brief hiatus eight simple rules
returned to television necessarily
revamped due to the loss of its star the
two-part episode goodbye reveals that
paul died after collapsing at the
grocery store in subsequent episodes
james garner and david spade joined the
cast as grandpa jim and nephew cj
respectively who move in to help the
widowed kate hennessey raise her three
kids
will lee was a regular presence on
sesame street from the beginning
portraying mr hooper the kindly
proprietor of hooper's store big bird
absolutely adores the sweet old man and
not just because he mixes up a mean bird
seed milkshake lee made public
appearances as mr hooper and recorded
segments for sesame street up until
november 1982. one month later lee died
of a heart attack in new york city's
lennox hill hospital at the age of 74. a
survey conducted shortly before his
death found that mr hooper was the most
recognized human adult on sesame street
in the wake of his passing sesame street
producers were left with the monumental
task of having to explain the death of
mr hooper and the concept of death in
general to an audience of extremely
young and emotionally vulnerable
children the series ultimately decided
to tackle this issue head-on with the
help of some consulting child
psychologists airing on thanksgiving day
1983 the absolutely heartbreaking
episode in question finds the childlike
big bird unable to locate mr hooper and
the adult on sesame street gently
explaining to him that the old
shopkeeper has died and the death is
final
you know
i'm gonna miss you mr looper
that's hooper big bird
as big bird learns it's okay to be sad
about loss but also that mr hooper will
live forever in the memories of all who
loved him
nicolas calisandro worked extensively in
television in the 1960s and 1970s both
as an actor and as a director in 1982 he
started work on cheers portraying ernie
pantuso the easygoing bartender who'd
once coached bar owner sam malone in his
baseball days coach became colossanto's
most recognizable role which is a truly
impressive feat given the breadth of his
career when he was cast on cheers
colossanto was well into his 50s and
already suffering from heart problems
his health took a turn for the worse in
late 1984
following a hospitalization for water in
his lungs he couldn't get medical
clearance to return to the rigors of
shooting cheers in february 1985 the 61
year old actor died of a heart attack a
few months later woody harrelson joined
the cast as cheers new bartender woody
boyd following a brief explanation of
coach's passing coach is mentioned
sporadically through the rest of the
show's run
phil hartman dominated saturday night
live during his nine-year stint on the
show but he then moved on to another
iconic ensemble show nbc's workplace
sitcom newsradio hartman played bill
mcneal an obnoxious rude self-absorbed
news reader for new york city radio
station wnyx he portrayed the part with
relish from 1995 to 1998 making his
final appearance in the titanic themed
fourth season finale in may 1998 before
the fifth season of news radio went into
production hartman's difficult marriage
to wife brynn omdahl ended an
unspeakable tragedy the deeply troubled
model and actress shot a sleeping
heartman to death then took her own life
hartman was just 49 years old
newsradio's fifth season which aired the
following fall begins with bill moves on
in which the wnyx team heads to the
office after the funeral of bill mcneil
said to have died from a heart attack
most of the episode consists of the
other characters talking about bill and
even openly crying tears that might well
have been real and could easily have
been shed for hartman himself
riverdale is the place where multiple
generations of iconic teen pop culture
converge based on the classic archie
comics stable of characters the cw
series deposits them in a dreary foggy
twin peaks like town absolutely rife
with dark doings many of the grown-ups
are portrayed by teen idols of yore
including 80s bratpacker molly ringwald
as archie's mother and beverly hills
90210's luke perry as archie's wise and
doting father fred andrews in the first
episode of season 4 archie finds out
that his father has unexpectedly been
killed by a hit and run driver after he
stopped to help a stranded motorist
played by perry's own 90210 love
interest shannon doherty that abrupt
choice came about due to the tragic
real-life death of the actor in february
2019 perry suffered a severe stroke at
the age of 52 and was immediately
hospitalized and placed in a medically
induced coma he died just a few days
later
the sopranos blew audiences away with
its uniquely thoughtful exploration of
what makes a man turn to a life of
violent crime tony soprano really is a
complicated guy he's a mob boss and a
family man who has his rivals killed but
then needs to discuss it with his
therapist and the sopranos suggests that
a lot of tony's anguish and emotional
pain stems from his mother livia a
manipulative self-serving and
conspiratorial abuser nancy martian
played the character with a fascinating
chilling intensity a four-time emmy
winner for her work on newspaper drama
lou grant martian added two more
nominations to a resume for portraying
livia the second however came
posthumously in june 2000 the 71 year
old marchand died of cancer and chronic
pulmonary disease the sopranos third
season hit hbo in early 2001 and in the
episode pro-shy levushka it's revealed
that livia soprano died in her sleep
having suffered a stroke
john spencer worked extensively from the
1960s onwards frequently playing tough
and world-weary cops lawyers soldiers
and a number of other authority figures
but they merely prepared him for his
signature role that of recovering
alcoholic and white house chief of staff
leo mcgarry on nbc's the west wing
spencer earned five emmy nominations for
this role finally winning the prize in
2002. in the show's seventh and final
season mcgarry is picked to be the vice
presidential candidate on the ticket of
presidential candidate matt santos the
duo wins the election although mcgeary
doesn't live to see it he dies of a
heart attack in his hotel room on
election night just before the polls
close
hey
he died
josh
this sad twist was necessitated by the
death of spencer who suffered a fatal
heart attack a few days before his 59th
birthday in december 2005.
andrew campbell wasn't a main character
on mad men but he was an influential one
the stern aloof and disapproving father
of slimy young advertising executive
pete campbell made quite the mark on his
son's psyche he appears in just one
first season episode 2007's new
amsterdam and could have eventually made
some return appearances if not for the
tragic and unexpected death of his actor
christopher albert in january 2008
albert was killed by an avalanche while
skiing in california's san gabriel
mountains in the second season episode
flight 1 employees at the sterling
cooper ad agency listened to radio news
about an american airlines flight that
crashed shortly after taking off from
new york city that is in fact an actual
tragedy that occurred in march 1962
another testament to the 60s set show's
commitment to historical accuracy later
in the episode pete learns that his
father was on the flight and that he
sadly didn't survive
larry hagman played one of the most
famous tv characters of all time but not
quite one of the most beloved from 1978
to 1991 he starred his backstabbing oil
magnate j.r ewing on dallas the texas
tycoon behaves so badly that somebody
was bound to take a shot at him and in
1980 somebody finally did the second
season of dallas ended on a cliffhanger
when an unidentified attacker guns down
jr leaving millions of viewers to wonder
if the character would survive he did
survive the shooting and ewing went on
to survive another brush with death in
the final episode of dallas when a ghost
convinces the wicked man to kill himself
whether j.r lives or dies isn't
explicitly revealed but modern fans can
assume he survived as he's a main
character in tnt's 2012 dallas
continuation shortly after the 2012
show's first season aired hagman died in
november 2012 at the age of 81 after a
fight against cancer so dallas decided
to have j.r ewing die too and riders
revived the who shot jr slogan to do it
in a 2013 episode an unidentified person
puts a bullet in the industrialist later
revealed to be a setup by jr himself to
arrange one more tricky business deal
while he dealt with his terminal cancer
portraying the dim but sweet finn hudson
on fox's musical dramedy glee was a
breakthrough role for canadian actor
corey monteith the likable star anchored
the popular teen show for four seasons
all the while quietly struggling with a
powerful drug addiction his mother anne
mcgregor told abc news that monteith
started using drugs at 15 and struggled
with substance addiction off and on for
the next decade and a half in july 2013
the body of the 31 year old actor was
found in his vancouver hotel room he had
died of a fatal overdose of heroin and
alcohol in october 2013 glee aired an
episode entitled the quarterback in
which finn's friends fellow club members
family and teachers all agonizingly
mourn their friend and colleague the
series also noticeably refuses to
discuss how finn died everyone wants to
talk about how he died too but who cares
one moment his whole life van is
remembered frequently through the rest
of the show's run if you or someone you
know is struggling with addiction please
call the substance abuse and mental
health administration's 24 7 national
helpline at
1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357
each and every episode of the warm
crackling low-key dramedy gilmore girls
features an odd credit special
appearance by edward herman
the actor appeared in many episodes so
he was a recurring cast member but this
unique introduction spoke to his status
as the best known and most esteemed
member of the gilmore girls ensemble
before he portrayed the wealthy and
impeccably dressed richard gilmore
hermann had portrayed president franklin
roosevelt in multiple tv projects have
been part of projects such as american
playhouse and sane elsewhere and served
as the voice of the history channel as
the new york times aptly put it he had
an unmistakably noble air gilmore girls
ended its original seven season run in
2007 but returned for four made for
netflix movie length episodes in 2016.
in the interim herman ultimately lost
his struggle with brain cancer spending
nearly a month in a new york intensive
care unit before passing away in
december 2014.
accordingly gilmore girls a year in the
life revolves around his character's
passing a few months before the events
of the mini-series richard gilmour dies
of a heart attack leaving the gilmore
women particularly his wife emily in
deep grief and struggling to find a way
to move on
lee thompson young became a teen tv star
by playing a teen tv star as jett
jackson on the disney channels the
famous jet jackson he portrayed a young
actor struggling with fame family and
school young successfully transitioned
to more adult projects but the most
prominent role of his adult life was
that of barry frost on rizzoli isles a
detective who often assists the titular
duo on august 19 2013 young failed to
report to the rizzoli isle set as
expected police went to his home to see
if he was alright and discovered that
the 29 year old actor had taken his own
life the show briefly shut down
production and in june 2014 addressed
the fate of young's character in the
episode goodbye frost is revealed to
have died off screen in a car accident
and the other characters attend his
memorial service
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call or chat
online with the national suicide
prevention lifeline at 1-800-273-talk
1-800-273-8255
a versatile character actor christopher
evan welch appeared in many films and tv
shows of the 21st century but he's
likely best known for what would turn
out to be his final role peter gregory
on silicon valley welch appeared in five
episodes of the first season of the hbo
tech world satire courted for his cash
by the main characters as they work to
launch a potentially revolutionary app
in december 2013 four months before
silicon valley debuted welch died in a
los angeles hospital at age 48 following
a years-long battle with lung cancer
silicon valley waited until its second
season premiere in 2015 to mention what
happened to peter gregory richard sees a
news item online about the investors
sudden death and later learns from
gregory's associate monica that he
keeled over during a safari while trying
to run from a stray hippo that had
wandered into his tent which in fairness
is a heck of a way to go
oh that is
so
very strange nice ad very sad tragic
it's true
if nothing else usa's 2002 series monk
is memorable for its unique tone it
follows a detective adrian monk who
often solves some serious grisly crimes
but monk is also a comedy with plenty of
carefully and consciously kind humor
derived from the title character's
obsessive-compulsive disorder helping to
strike that balance was the character of
dr charles kroger monk's patient and
helpful psychiatrist who works with him
to deal with his ocd and lingering grief
over the death of his wife so it was a
major blow to the show when the actor
who portrayed him stanley camel passed
away from a heart attack in april 2008
the first episode of the show's seventh
season the first without camel aired in
july 2008 with a dedication to the actor
it's mentioned in dialogue that dr
kroger similarly died of a heart attack
angel is a show about ageless beings and
supernatural events so death isn't all
that final a concept for its various
vampires demons and
angels when the buffy the vampire slayer
spinoff premiered in 1999 there were
only three main characters one of them
being doyle a half demonic hero who
receives alarming visions that vampire
detective angel uses to solve his
mysteries portraying the ampish irish
rogue was glenn quinn previously known
for his work as becky's nerdy well
husband mark on roseanne in hiro the
ninth episode of angel doyle sacrifices
his own life to save angels and never
appears on the show again however
frequent angel writer and director tom
miner really wanted to bring doyle back
he told an angel fan blog in 2007 every
once in a while i'd bring it up but i'd
get shot down any hopes of doyle's
return were rendered impossible however
in 2002 when quinn died of a drug
overdose at age 32. years later his
roseanne character was also written out
of the show an episode of the 2018
reboot series mentions that mark has
died and ends with a dedication to quinn
himself
it's arguably easier for an animated
series to handle the death of a cast
member as the performer's image is not
used producers can get a new sound alike
actor to take over a role vacated by a
death case in point actress gray delisle
griffin became the new martin prince on
the simpsons after the death of original
actor rusi taylor in 2019 this is
largely because the show's writers were
anxious about killing off a child
character but that's not the direction
they took when marsha wallace died in
october 2013. wallace used her
distinctive voice to play bart simpson's
sarcastic and long-suffering 4th grade
teacher mrs kerbopel for well over 20
years as it turns out wallace simply
wasn't replaceable and so her character
was retired about a week after the 70
year old passed away the simpsons paid
tribute in an episode's opening credits
bart's chalkboard message that week
reads we'll really miss you mrs k a
march 2014 episode includes an epilogue
in which krabappel's husband ned
flanders day dreams about their good
times together and is joined in mourning
by one of her students nelson muntz
tv creates kind of an immortality for
its actors that can seem surreal so it
can be jarring to learn that certain
stars of the small screen have died with
that in mind here are some sitcom actors
who you may not have known and passed
away
from 1986 to 1990 nbc fell in love with
alf a fuzzy smart mouthed alien from the
planet melmac who occasionally tried to
eat the family cat the father of that
family was willie tanner played by max
wright he was the straight man to the
wisecracking alf puppet an experience
that eventually soured him enough that
he reportedly didn't bother saying
goodbye to anyone on his last day of
work on the series in 1995 wright was
diagnosed with lymphoma which went into
remission after radiation and
chemotherapy treatments his work was on
the decline after alf but after his
diagnosis and subsequent remission he
started to find joy again in 2000 he
told people magazine i came back to life
after being on the edge with a
tremendous gusto for the things i love
among other things wright landed a
regular gig on the norm mcdonald sitcom
norm and received a tony nomination for
his work on the anton chekhov play
ivanov unfortunately wright's lymphoma
didn't stay in remission and he
succumbed to the disease in 2019 at the
age of 75.
lisa robin kelly is best known for her
role as lori forman on that 70s show for
the first five seasons she played eric's
older sister but in the sixth season she
was replaced by christina moore in 2012
kelly told abc news that alcoholism was
the reason for her departure and she
also said that her alcohol abuse began
after she suffered a miscarriage as she
explained it i had lost a baby as a
result of that i lost it i lost
everything and i was abusing alcohol at
the time kelly said that she was ready
for a comeback but unfortunately that
wasn't in the cards from 2010 to 2013
she had a number of run-ins with the law
she was charged with driving under the
influence in 2010 and in 2013 she was
arrested for dui again when she
reportedly parked her car on
california's i-5 freeway blocking the
lane of traffic she was also arrested
for some violent crimes she was charged
with corporal injury upon a spouse in
march 2012. and that november both she
and her husband robert joseph gillum
were arrested after an alleged domestic
disturbance kelly's battle with
addiction didn't end well she died
shortly after checking into rehab in
august 2013. the los angeles county
coroner deemed that her death was due to
combined drug intoxication in an
accidental overdose she was 43.
john ritter was a staple of american tv
for decades best known as jack tripper
on the long-running sitcom 3's company
he didn't slow down after that show
where its spin-offs ended in the late
80s he helped coin the term dramedy with
the abc show hooperman in the early 90s
he led the political satire hearts of
fire as senatorial aide john hartman he
also had memorable film appearances like
1996 oscar-winning slingblade ritter's
final role was protective father paul
hennessey on the abc sitcom eight simple
rules in september 2013 while rehearsing
for the show he was taken to the
hospital after vomiting and complaining
of chest pains initially he was treated
for a heart attack but it was later
discovered that he had a tear in his
aorta he died during surgery a week shy
of his 55th birthday this wasn't
supposed to happen mom
not now
when we were old and gray
and living someplace warm
shelly morrison enjoyed a long fruitful
acting career including regular
appearances as sister sisto on the sally
field starring 60s sitcom the flying nun
but the role she became best known for
wouldn't come until 1999 with the season
one finale of will and grace rosario is
mentioned as early as the series
premiere but we don't actually meet her
until the season 1 finale when karen
gets jack to marry rosario so she won't
be deported rosario wasn't meant to show
up beyond that episode but she proved to
be popular enough to stick around while
she works as karen's maid over the
course of the series it's eventually
revealed that she has a degree in
clinical psychology performed with
jennifer lopez and somehow rakes in 350
000 per year morrison was asked to
reprise the role for the 2017 will and
grace revival but by that point she had
retired from acting for good in december
2019 news broke that she had passed away
from heart failure after a brief illness
at the age of 83.
rosie and i would do other normal couple
things you know like get into a fight at
ikea
while he died much too young merlin
santana had a decades-long career in
sitcoms in the early 90s he played the
recurring role of stanley boyfriend of
rudy huxbl on the cosby show shortly
after his character marcus proved to be
one of the most popular parts of getting
by a short-lived sitcom about two single
mothers and their children merlin's last
big regular sitcom spot was as young
ladies man romeo santana on the wb's the
steve harvey show that show ended in
2002 the same year that santana was
killed in his car in los angeles he was
only 26 years old when he was shot in
the head by a man named damian andre
gates who apparently erroneously
believed that santana had been making
advances toward his girlfriend gates was
sentenced to three consecutive life
sentences plus 70 years in prison for
killing santana and for attempting to
kill fellow actor brandon quinton adams
who was in the car with santana during
home improvements eight seasons one of
the most popular characters was also its
least visible with his face always
obscured usually by offense earl
heineman's wilson w wilson jr doled out
yoda-like wisdom to the tool obsessed
tim taylor audiences didn't get to see
wilson's entire face until the series
finale's curtain call though in the
meantime the show occasionally had fun
with the audience by showing the bottom
half of his face but not the top
heinmann had been working in film and tv
since the 60s mainly in smaller roles
his big screen credits include the 1981
military school drama taps and the 1985
western silverado before home
improvement he was best known as
detective lieutenant bob reed on the
soap opera ryan's hope four years after
home improvement ended the man behind
wilson had to give another goodbye in
december 2003 hyneman died of lung
cancer at the age of 61. while it's not
the only thing he ever did gary coleman
will always be remembered for the role
of arnold jackson on different strokes
arnold was the younger of two
harlem-born brothers taken in by
successful businessman philip drummond
todd bridges played arnold's older
brother willis the namesake of coleman's
classic catchphrase
coleman dealt with severe health issues
his whole life while he was adamant
about not publicly sharing specifics it
is known that his short stature was due
to kidney disease he underwent at least
two kidney transplants that were
ultimately unsuccessful a year before
his passing he had heart surgery after
which he was seriously ill with
pneumonia while nothing has been made
officially public it seems likely that
one or more of these issues ultimately
led to coleman's death he passed away in
2010 after falling down the stairs in
his home and hitting his head he'd
suffered a number of seizures in the
preceding months and it's believed that
those seizures may have been what caused
the fall the injury eventually led to a
brain hemorrhage from which he didn't
recover and while that storyline is too
familiar a famous kid struggling to find
his way as an adult only to die young
each time it's just as tragic
years before will smith was punching out
aliens he was better known as half of
the hip-hop duo dj jazzy jeff and the
fresh prince that fame helped him
eventually bridge the worlds of hip-hop
and acting with the nbc sitcom the fresh
prince of bel-air smith played a
fictionalized version of himself who
sent to live with his aunt and uncle in
the los angeles neighborhood bel air
after a confrontation with a violent
gang over the course of the series james
avery would become one of the most
well-loved father figures on american tv
as smith's uncle phil besides fresh
prince avery was also known for his
exceptional voice work he was the voice
of shredder in the original teenage
mutant ninja turtles animated series and
of james rhodes aka war machine in the
90's iron man cartoon as for his live
action work he didn't have too many huge
roles besides uncle phil in a 2007
interview with the new york film academy
he was candid about missing out on the
spotlight saying you can either be a
movie star or an actor i'm an actor but
i've done pretty good avery died in
december 2013 due to complications from
open-heart surgery he was 68.
in the first four seasons of the 80s
sitcom growing pains andrew koenig
played boner best friend to kirk
cameron's mike siever his character left
the show in season 4 to drop out of
college and join the marine corps kane's
acting work after growing pains wasn't
extensive though he had some other
memorable claims to fame he was the son
of walter koenig best known as the
original chekhov on star trek andrew
koenig also starred in one of the most
famous fan films of all time he played
the joker in batman dead end in which
the dark knight finds himself facing the
xenomorphs from the alien films as well
as the ruthless hunters from the
predator franchise in the 90s and 2000s
koenig became an outspoken activist and
gained notoriety in his efforts to draw
more attention to china's support to the
military dictatorship ruling burma in
2008 he was arrested for interrupting
pasadena's rose parade by blocking a
float advertising the beijing summer
olympics and holding up a sign that said
china free burma in february 2010
kanye's body was found hanging from a
tree in vancouver's stanley park his
father confirmed at a press conference
that his son had taken his own life he
later wrote on his website that andrew
died after a long battle with depression
and urged other depression sufferers to
reach out for help david strickland's
acting career was tragically short in
the 90s he had popular recurring roles
on the sitcom's sister sister and mad
about you in 1996 he was tapped for the
part he'll forever be known for young
eager rock reporter todd on the brook
shield starring suddenly susan behind
the scenes strickland suffered from
mental health and substance abuse issues
his suddenly susan co-star nestor
carbonell told people magazine in 1999
if he had an episode where he fell off
the wagon it would be once every two
months sometimes once every six months
he'd have a bad episode and we'd all
worry about it for a night or two and
he'd resurface as if nothing had
happened he'd always resurface
strickland was reportedly off his
prescribed medication and upset about
much of his role in the 1999 rom-com
forces of nature being left on the
cutting room floor when he and andy dick
flew to las vegas in march 1999 the pair
reportedly bounced from strip club to
strip club partying hard and on march
22nd strickland was found in his motel
room where he'd hanged himself with a
bed sheet the writers of suddenly susan
decided to have art imitate life in the
season 3 finale todd's co-workers panic
when he goes missing they tell stories
about him interspersed with clips of
out-of-character interviews with a cast
the episode ends with the police calling
to report his fate which is left
ambiguous
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273
8255
sadly 2020 has already proven to be a
year in which we've lost some big names
even in just a few short months from
founding fathers of comedy and veteran
character actors to up-and-coming stars
that never got a chance to shine here
are the actors we've lost in 2020 so far
hollywood legend kurt douglas the
patriarch of the douglas dynasty died in
february 2020 at the age of 103 his son
actor michael douglas confirmed his
death via instagram he wrote he leaves a
legacy and film that will endure for
generations to come
born in new york as iser danielovic
douglas made his broadway debut in 1941.
his career was interrupted by the
outbreak of world war ii but douglas
returned to the stage after being
honorably discharged from the navy in
1944 and before long hollywood beckoned
1949's champion made him a star and gave
him his first of three oscar nominations
but his most famous picture is stanley
kubrick's spartacus douglas famously
spoke out in favor of blacklisted
screenwriter dalton trumbo insisting he
was properly credited for his work on
spartacus douglas later wrote in his
autobiography i think one of the most
important things in my career was the
breaking of the blacklist in the same
book douglas also discussed his regrets
after starring in a stage adaptation of
one flew over the cuckoo's nest he tried
for years to get a film version made by
the time it happened douglas was too old
to reprise the role of mcmurphy which
went to jack nicholson douglas wrote i
made more money from that film than any
i acted in and i would gladly get back
every cent if i could have played that
role
terry jones best known for his work with
the groundbreaking british comedy troupe
monty python passed away in january 2020
after battling a rare form of dementia
in a statement his family said
we have all lost a kind funny warm
creative and truly loving man whose
uncompromising individuality relentless
intellect and extraordinary humor have
given pleasure to countless millions
across six decades jones was 77 years
old early in his career he had been
instrumental in developing the unique
stream of consciousness style that made
monty python's flying circus the
game-changing tv show it was and he
would later go on to spearhead three of
the group's original feature films
1975's mighty python and the holy grail
which he co-directed with terry gilliam
is regularly ranked among the funniest
films ever made jones then went on to
helm 1979's monty python's life of brian
in which he played the titular
character's cantankerous mother and
delivered the film's most iconic line oh
now you listen here it
is a very naughty boy now go away
finally jones directed 1983's monty
python's the meaning of life the last
movie to feature all six pythons the
remaining members of the influential
troupe paid tribute to jones following
his passing fellow python michael palin
said he was far more than one of the
funniest writer performers of his
generation he was the complete
renaissance comedian writer director
presenter historian brilliant children's
author and the warmest most wonderful
company you could wish to have
ugandan actress nikita aligwa who
starred in the 2016 disney film queen of
cutway died from a brain tumor in
february 2020. she was first diagnosed
with a tumor in 2016 but thanks to a
fundraising effort was flown to india
for treatment and soon got the all clear
a second tumor developed however and
this time she couldn't be saved she was
just 15 years old queen of cutway is a
biographical drama about real-life chess
player fiona mutesi a poor ugandan girl
who went from the slums of cotway to the
world chess olympiads while igua played
mutesi's real-life friend and fellow
chess star gloria nansobaga who was
shocked when she heard the news she told
the bbc i couldn't bear to hear that
someone who acted as me in a film had
died i loved her from my heart actor
david oyelowo an oscar winner lupita
nyong'o who also starred in the movie
both took to instagram to pay tribute to
the team nyong'o wrote she played gloria
with cech vibrancy in her real life she
had the enormous challenge of battling
brain cancer my thoughts and prayers are
with her family and community as they
come to terms with having to say goodbye
so soon oyelowo echoed those sentiments
calling waligwa's battle humbling to
witness in his own post he said she was
a ball of light her light will live on
both a brilliant character actor and
star of numerous oscar-winning movies
actor jack kehoe passed away in january
2020. the queen's born actor lived in
the hollywood hills but had been out of
the spotlight since suffering a stroke
in 2015. he was 85. kehoe joined the
army straight out of high school and
served three years with 101st airborne
division he trained in the performance
arts under stella adler after leaving
the military and soon hit the stage
putting in an acclaimed performance in
the eugene o'neill play a moon for the
misbegotten this opened the door to
hollywood where kiho would establish
himself as a capable foil for some of
the biggest stars of the time and where
he would star alongside some of the
world's most iconic actors too sally
kirkland who co-starred with kehoe and
the sting paid tribute to her late
colleague on twitter she wrote he was a
wonderful character actor who was
unforgettable in serpico and the
untouchables god bless his beautiful
soul journey home to the heart of god
star of a number of different tv shows
and low budget movies australian actor
harry haynes passed away in january 2020
at the age of 27. his mother confirmed
his death in an instagram post writing
he had the world at his feet but sadly
he struggled with mental illness and
addiction a brilliant spark shown bright
too short a time i will miss you harry
every day of my life the los angeles
county medical examiner coroner's office
announced in early march 2020 that
haynes died of fentanyl intoxication
haynes was genderfluid and spoke openly
about his desire to become the first
genderfluid icon when he sat down with
close-up culture to talk about his
musical project anti-boy he said he'd
always dislike the idea of labels haynes
explained it's like feeling like
something is wrong with you because
society has told you that you need to
behave and act a certain way and you see
a professional and they diagnose you
with a mental disorder he continued i
would rather look at the environment and
see what is causing these feelings of
negativity and discomfort to solve the
issue rather than put a band-aid over it
new york actor stan kirsch best known
for playing richie ryan in the
highlander television series and for a
memorable appearance on the iconic
sitcom friends tragically took his own
life in january 2020. he was 51. after
sharing the news on facebook kirsch's
wife kristen greene wrote i want to
thank everyone for the outpouring of
love and support
kirsch began his tv career with bit
parts on a variety of shows throughout
the early 90s he made his debut as
streetwise punk turned immortal richard
h ryan in 1992 and would go on to appear
in over a hundred episodes of highlander
over the next six years an official
statement on the show's facebook page
read without stan kirsch highlander the
series would have been far less he
brought a sense of humor kindness and
youthful enthusiasm to the character of
richie ryan in the middle of his run on
highlander kirsch landed a spot on
friends playing the way too young still
in high school boyfriend of monica
kirsch was also a well-known acting
coach
best known for playing josephine on the
cbs sitcom king of queens character
actor norma michaels died in january
2020. her obituary confirmed that she
passed away peacefully at her palm
springs home she was 95.
michael's worked on seven episodes of
king of queens just one of the many
comedies she popped up in over the
course of a career that began back in
the mid 50s in later years she appeared
on pretty much every major sitcom or
comedy from the 90s and 2000s with her
final tv role being an appearance in the
hit cop comedy brooklyn nine-nine it's
going so
slow there we go
oh
my glasses all right let's go to 5'4 but
michaels wasn't a one-trick pony in fact
she had some serious acting shops too
paying tribute to michael screenwriter
christopher kubasic recalled being blown
away by her skill when he worked with
her on the fantasy drama series the
booth at the end kubasik tweeted it was
so committed and sensitive of
performance i could feel an unexpected
energy spread across the crew as
everyone got the show in that moment i
was so grateful to norma
william bogart who is best known for his
role as brandon brindle in the 80s
sci-fi sitcom small wonder died in
january 2020. the actor passed away in
his home state of new york at the age of
83. bogart made his debut starring in a
1964 political ad called confessions of
a republican in which he delivers a
monologue about the dangers of trusting
republican presidential nominee barry
goldwater the ad went viral in 2016 when
people started to notice eerie
similarities between goldwater and
republican then candidate donald trump
berger was a staunch republican when he
filmed the ad but his loyalties changed
over the years and he reprised the
character in a campaign video for
hillary clinton bogart started landing
regular tv roles after the ad aired and
went on to appear in 28 episodes of
small wonder which followed a family of
robotics engineers booger was also seen
on the big screen most notably in 1983's
war games playing matthew broderick's
father in the cold war sci-fi classic
bogart's wife aaron oscar was a
puppeteer best known for her work on the
muppet show she passed away in 1993.
tv and theater actress marsha cramer
passed away in january 2020. her death
was confirmed by director jeff greenberg
who had worked with her on the abc
sitcom modern family he tweeted so sad
to hear that my longtime friend marsha
kramer passed away yesterday at the age
of 74. she was so delightful in the 14
episodes she shot as margaret on modern
family over the last seven years but
i'll always remember her soaring aloft
as wendy greenberg was referring to the
1979 broadway revival of peter pan in
which kramer played wendy darling
opposite sandy duncan in the title role
she also appeared in a number of other
stage and small screen roles over the
years popping up in everything from dr
ken to days of our lives modern family
was her most notable screen role but
kramer also had a number of credits on a
range of sitcoms including malcolm in
the middle and fraser on which she
played the off-mentioned rarely seen
radio host tutti
brooklyn native john carlin best known
for his roles in dark shadows and cagney
and lacey passed away in january 2020.
the dark shadows news twitter page
confirmed that he died at a hospice in
california having suffered a number of
health setbacks over the past decade a
family spokesman later confirmed the
cause of death as congestive heart
failure he was 86.
carlin a korean war vet made his acting
debut in 1960 replacing the late rip
torn in a broadway production of the
tennessee williams classic sweet bird of
youth six years later he won the part of
willie lomas the con artist who
unwittingly frees vampire barnabas
collins in dark shadows carlin remained
a fan favorite when the show ended
attending events and conventions after
winning a primetime emmy for his work on
cagney and lacy in 1987 he told the
chicago tribune i'm 40 pounds heavier
and i have a mustache but people still
recognize me carlin appeared in 124
episodes of cagney and lacy laying the
latter's dependable husband harvey it
wasn't the meatiest of roles but it was
one that carlin relished all the same he
later said the secret of harvey lacy is
that he's liked harvey being shuffled
into the background doesn't bother me he
reprised the role for 1996's cagney and
lacy true convictions which was his last
feature-length performance
raspy voiced actor kevin conway famed
for his explosive performances on the
stage and screen passed away in february
2020. his longtime partner geraldine
newman told the new york times that the
harlem native died of a heart attack he
was 77. conway joined the navy after
graduating from brooklyn's bishop
lockland high school in 1959 when he
left the military he secured a mail room
job at ibm and was actively working his
way up the company ladder when he
decided he wanted a change of direction
he enrolled in acting classes and began
landing stage roles first in
off-broadway productions and later on
broadway proper conway played dr trevis
and bernard pomerantz's the elephant man
a role he reprised for a televised
performance of the play hollywood saw
conway as a tough guy when he first went
west the new yorker threw his weight
about in the late 70s sylvester stallone
flicks fist and paradise alley but as he
got older the offers became more varied
he turned down the chance to play king
theoden in the lord of the rings a
decision he came to regret and sadly he
would never get an opportunity quite
like that again still conway worked
steadily as a voice actor and narrator
in the last few years of his life
missouri born actress lynne cohen may
have appeared in dozens of big films and
tv shows over the course of her career
but she was perhaps best known for her
role as the hilariously prank
housekeeper magda in sex and the city
cohen passed away in february 2020 at
the age of 86. described by deadline as
a staple in the new york theater
community cohen earned several awards
for her work on the stage her film debut
came in 1983 when she played a minor
part in the mystery drama without a
trace but her career on screen wouldn't
start to pick up steam until the late
90s she appeared in 10 feature films
between 1996 and 2000 when she made her
debut on sex in the city cohen had done
tv before but portraying cynthia nixon's
ukrainian maid and nanny on the smash
hit hbo show exposed her to whole new
levels of fame no no no no no
yes
she reprised the role of magda in the
2008 sex and the city movie as well as
its 2010 sequel several former sex and
the city cast members took to social
media after hearing about cohen's
passing the leading lady included sarah
jessica parker wrote on an instagram
post beautiful lynn cohen miranda's dear
and necessary magda our dear satc
colleague talent race inspiration r.i.p
meanwhile actor willie garson tweeted
bless you and godspeed our wonderful
magda for 15 years of episodes and films
thank you for your friendship and
amazing talent
hawaii born actress kelly nakahara died
of cancer in february 2020 surrounded by
her loved ones at her home in california
she was 72 years old nakahara was best
known for her role as nurse kelly on the
classic army hospital dramedy mash her
sister nalani coleman told cnn she was a
performer and an artist and she did her
artwork to make people happy which in
turn gave her joy people wanted to be
near her she was genuine in her persona
nakahara was only supposed to be an
extra on mash but she had different
plans she once explained i put myself in
every scene and nobody told me to get
out and that tactic worked perfectly she
ended up featuring in 167 episodes of
the korean war set show even playing the
lead on occasion alan alda who portrayed
surgeon hawkeye pierce told fox news she
was adorable and brilliant in the park
but you couldn't beat what she was as a
person funnier and warmer and kinder
than most people i've known
actress and musician janae dubois best
known for playing fashionable divorcee
willowna woods on the 70s sitcom good
times passed away in her california home
in february 2020. according to her
family she was 74 at the time although
the new york times reported that public
records indicated she may actually have
been older dubois was born in
philadelphia but moved to new york to
pursue a career in acting she appeared
in several broadway productions and ran
her own acting workshop for kids at one
stage but by the 1960s hollywood was
calling the ambitious performer was cast
in good times in 1974 portraying
willowna woods until 1979 and appearing
in a total of 133 episodes of the norman
lear sitcom during her stint on good
times dubois told lear that she wanted
to explore new avenues and he suggested
that she create a song for the
jeffersons one of the prolific producers
many shows the result was moving on up
which according to the new york times
became one of the era's most iconic
theme songs as well as an empowering
aspirational song for black americans
dubois daughter kisha gupta fields later
said it provided a lot of black people
with an anthem the philly native went on
to appear in a handful of feature films
in the years that followed but she was
always more celebrated for her tv work
dubois also won two primetime emmys for
her work on eddie murphy and larry
wilmore's animated series the pjs in
which she voiced the quarrelsome housing
project resident mrs avery
swedish-born actor max von cedo best
known to american audiences for playing
father murren in the exorcist and ming
the merciless and flash gordon passed
away in march 2020 he was 90 years old
the imposing european landed on
hollywood's radar after appearing in a
string of movies by acclaimed swedish
filmmaker ingmar bergman fonsito
initially spurned u.s advances but when
the chance to play jesus christ and the
greatest story ever told came his way in
1965 he decided to take his talent
stateside the exorcist and flash gordon
further established him in america
though he would go on to be typecast as
a swab evil doer in the years that
followed most notably in 1983's never
say never again where he played classic
bond villain blowfield in the sean
connery flick vancito stayed active late
into his career appearing in a number of
big hollywood franchises he portrayed
explorer lor san tekka in 2015 star wars
episode vii the force awakens and later
appeared in three episodes of game of
thrones playing the all-knowing
three-eyed raven director edgar wright
led the tributes on twitter calling
voncito a quote iconic presence in
cinema for seven decades he is survived
by his wife catherine and four sons
sadly these aren't the only actors who
have left us in 2020 here are some of
the other stars who enhanced our lives
before leaving us all too soon john
shrapnel esther scott jason davis rafael
coleman if you or anyone you know is
having suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk
8255
[Music]
turns out the man most famous for
playing the wizarding world's nastiest
teacher was also a dedicated friend a
mentor and an enormous amount of fun to
be around who'd have guessed it alan
rickman might be gone but he left us a
lot to think about and a lot to take his
inspiration in january 2016 rickman died
of pancreatic cancer at 69 he was no
spring chicken but he wasn't
particularly old either fans around the
world mourned the untimely nature of his
passing and its seeming suddenness had
anyone known he was sick how long had he
been suffering and how severely had it
been publicized how could one beloved
man's passing in an age of such
unprecedented interconnectivity so shock
the entire world simply put it was a
secret the first new thing the world
learned about alan rickman upon his
death was that he had been battling
pancreatic cancer for a few months prior
after being diagnosed in august
following a small stroke pancreatic
cancer sometimes called a silent cancer
takes time to present any symptoms and
is often found after a seemingly
unconnected problem surfaces rickman
decided to keep the news confined to
close friends and family and soldiered
on with his work as it happened no one
knew what they were going to lose until
he was already gone the rickman
portrayed many noteworthy characters
severus snape harry potter's grouchy
potions professor might be the most
memorable of all snape is vindictive
moody and even in his moments of bravery
deeply and unrelentingly cynical it's a
fine edge to dance upon but rickman made
it look easy for eight films he
portrayed snape with caustic aplomb and
that performance has become nothing less
than iconic that is the second time
you've spoken out of turn miss granger
are you incapable of restraining
yourself or do you take pride in being
an insufferable know-it-all
he's got a point you know by all
accounts it was also the role that had
least to do with his actual personality
when remembering the actor posthumously
colleagues and friends have repeatedly
touched upon his unrelenting kindness
and generosity of spirit in a tribute
for entertainment weekly kate winslet
mused if there was one word i could use
to really describe al it would be kind
he was so kind whenever al would go out
to supper and anyone else would try and
pay he would somehow have phoned ahead
or slipped his credit card ahead of the
meal so no one even got a look at the
check tales of helping hands thoughtful
gifts and general friendliness seemed to
surround rickman's legacy he wasn't just
passively kind but actively generous
which is about as far from snape as you
can get younger fans will never know how
heated the debate over snape's true
loyalties grew back when the harry
potter saga was still a work in progress
snape's motivations were murky and his
actions ambiguous until the very end
when it was finally revealed that he was
on the side of the angels all along
motivated by his deep and lasting love
for harry's mother lily though some had
guessed no one knew the full truth for
sure until the story's very final
chapters no one that is except alan
rickman it's since come to light that
author jk rowling told rickman the truth
about snape's motivations years earlier
to help inform his performance according
to rowling what she told them boiled
down to just one word
[Music]
if you revisit the potter films this
knowledge will become more readily
apparent in rickman's performance
although he is sour unrelentingly harsh
and sometimes even outright cruel he
returns over and over again to the side
of light and love his anger at harry
appears so much more nuanced than at
first glance and his frustration with
the growing darkness around him more
pronounced snape was always much more
than he seemed and rickman made that
apparent in everything from overt
declarations of loyalty to the subtlest
most fleeting glances though rickman's
trademark style and double bass voice
made every role he took on memorable in
its own right arguably one of his best
was alexander dain in 1999's galaxy
quest also an actor the character of
dane feels degraded by his role as dr
lazarus on the in-universe star trek
equivalent galaxy quest which requires
the use of a complicated and silly
looking skull prosthetic as well as a
horde of alien catchphrases
by grab thaw's hammer
[Music]
what a savings
galaxy quest became an instant cult hit
and is often hailed in star trek fandom
as a better trek movie than some of the
official outings rickman's performance
in particular of course is held to be
one of the film's most memorable so it's
probably no surprise to find that a
sequel was in the works which was kept
totally under wraps until rickman's
tragic passing put an end to the project
it's a bittersweet turn of events that
acts as both a testament to rickman's
acting and a sad reminder of what could
have been there are few relationships in
the harry potter series more charged and
complex than the one between harry and
snape after all harry potter and the
half-blood prince pretty much translates
as harry potter and severus snape snape
basically gives his life to protect
harry yet bullies him relentlessly for
years meanwhile harry loathes snape to
the point of obsession yet ends up
naming a son after him the relationship
sits at the heart of the series and the
crux of harry's journey it's only
appropriate then that alan rickman
matters so deeply to daniel radcliffe in
a facebook post made after rickman's
death radcliffe hailed him as one of the
greatest actors he would ever work with
he continued he is also one of the
loyalist and most supportive people i've
ever met in the film industry radcliffe
went on to detail rickman's kindness and
generosity his mastery of the craft of
acting and his wit adding one
particularly heart-wrenching detail i'm
pretty sure he came and saw everything i
ever did on stage both in london and new
york rickman's dedication to performance
was legendary but it was easily
surpassed by his devotion to his fellow
performers
thanks to the memorable characters they
brought to life on the big screen and on
our tvs these actors will never really
leave us in fact they'll always be there
exactly the way we remember them they'll
never be more than a few clicks away
former child actor john paul stoyer who
played a young klingon on star trek the
next generation died on january 1st at
the age of 33. sawyer began
professionally acting at the age of four
and was the first actor to play
alexander the mostly klingon son of warf
on star trek the next generation he
portrayed the character in one episode
reunion and other actors went on to play
the role at various ages why can't i
stay with you
you deserve
he's perhaps best known for playing
brett butler's eldest son on the sitcom
grace under fire from 1993 until leaving
the show in 1996. you're not sitting up
here making plans to be dysfunctional
are you
what's dysfunctional he later said he
quit acting in part because of butler's
erratic behavior and controversy
surrounding the series his death was
announced on the facebook page of the
rock band problems in which stoyer sang
under the name johnny p jewels for about
a year
watch out for salami
former child actor joseph wayne miller
made his breakthrough in the 1995 comedy
heavyweights according to tmz he died in
his sleep on january 9th at the age of
36. miller played the character of
salami sam in heavyweights which was
co-written and produced by judd apatow
in a statement to page six apatow said
we could not have loved spending time
with him more he made everyone around
him so happy what a terrible loss
hey what's up i'm virtually here vern
troyer stood at two feet eight inches
and was born with a chondroplasia
dwarfism a condition that causes
cartilage to not properly convert to
bones often resulting in undersized arms
and legs in 2012 he told jonathan ross
you're born kind of proportioned and
you know you look
pretty much normal except for being
small he grew up in an amish community
in michigan and achieved fame when he
debuted opposite mike myers in 1999's
austin powers the spy who shagged me
troyer had more than 50 acting credits
in movies and on television including
roles as grip hook and harry potter and
the sorcerer's stone and coach punch
jerkoff in the love guru vern troyer
died on april 21st at the age of 49.
according to people his death was noted
by the coroner as possibly being a
suicide via alcohol poisoning an
announcement on troyer's facebook page
read it is with great sadness and
incredibly heavy hearts to write that
vern passed away today vern was an
extremely caring individual he wanted to
make everyone smile be happy and laugh
actress pamela gidley passed away at the
age of 52 on april 16th dying peacefully
in her new hampshire home an actress
since 1986 gidley's debut role was in
the skateboarding movie thrashin in
which she starred alongside childhood
friend sherilyn finn and josh brolin he
says they pay a thousand dollars to the
winner of some race
there's no little racer to downhill
early in her career the model turned
actress played an android in the cult
sci-fi comedy movie cherry 2000. she
went on to have a notable role in the
1992 twin peaks prequel film fire walk
with me in 1992 gidley had a regular
role on the buddy cop series angel
street on cbs starring opposite robin
givens as a chicago homicide detective
her last credited role was in twin peaks
the missing pieces a long lost
compilation of extended and deleted
scenes from twin peaks firewalk with me
perhaps best known for playing lois lane
in the superman film series actress
margot kidder died on may 13 2018 at her
home in montana she was 69 years old
kidder moved to los angeles shortly
after graduating high school in order to
pursue acting in the late 60s the whole
idea was to get wildly out of control
and see how far you could go before you
crashed
in 1972 she moved to new york city and
scored a role in the bryan de palma
movie sisters a critically acclaimed
psychological thriller but her on-screen
coupling with superman played by
christopher reeve really put her on the
map
should we get on with the interview
yes
the romance between the two characters
played out across four films between
1978 and 1987. kitter was known for a
variety of other roles with performances
in the horror movies black christmas and
the amityville horror the actress
suffered from mental illness all her
life and a 1996 bipolar episode led to a
high-profile disappearance she opened up
about her struggle to canada am in 2003.
i attempted suicide several times yeah i
just always assumed i'd never get to be
this old i'm a grandmother now as she
told the idaho press tribune in 2017 she
remained actively involved in causes she
believed in protesting against war and
the excesses of the energy industry i've
mostly been doing political activism i
was at standing rock in a tent for four
months
anthony bourdain was a writer presenter
producer and performer who helped shape
how we see international food culture he
died on june 8th in france at the age of
61. bourdain rose to prominence in 2000
on the back of his best-selling book
kitchen confidential adventures in the
culinary underbelly by the time it was
published he'd already gathered more
than 20 years of experience in the
kitchen and his unapologetic attitude
and confessional style helped endear him
to a large audience detoxing from what
when heroin added i mean
the book was adapted into a television
series in 2005 starring bradley cooper
as a bad boy chef based on bourdain
himself that image helped make bourdain
a charismatic presence on the
international food scene he started
appearing on television as the host of
food networks at cook's tour an
adaptation of bourdain's second book
bourdain continued his career as a host
with the series no reservations the
layover and anthony bourdain parts
unknown his notoriety also led to
winking cameo appearances in film and
television with bourdain appearing as
himself in the 2015 film the big short
it's not old fish it's a whole new thing
that is a cdl
he was decorated with awards from the
entertainment industry for his work
earning five emmys and a peabody award
bourdain tragically died of an apparent
suicide by hanging his body discovered
by a friend and colleague in his france
hotel room on the morning of june 8.
during his life the chef made no secret
of his struggles with depression and
history of self-destructive behavior
remarking in one 2016 interview i should
have died in my 20s
burt reynolds was a movie star known for
his displays of genial charm and unique
charisma over the course of his storied
50-year career he died on september 6th
at the age of 82 born on february 11
1936 reynolds began his career on
broadway and television shows he went on
to leave his mark on american cinema
through appearances in a number of
successful films including deliverance
the longest yard and smokey in the
bandit we have a big chance
a big chance
to make a run
for some big bucks
80 000
his outsized persona and sex symbol
status made him a fixture of pop culture
in the 1970s and 80s and he enjoyed wild
success between 1978 and 1982 as the
industry's top grossing movie star
despite his natural talents as a box
office draw reynolds spent much of his
career seeking validation as an actor
rarely earning much critical respect for
his performances in his 2015 memoir he
claimed he didn't start challenging
himself as a performer until he was
older being more interested in leading
an exciting life and cultivating a body
of work for his work in boogie nights he
was nominated for an academy award for
best supporting actor he lost the oscar
but won a golden globe he also won two
golden globes and an emmy for his work
on the comedy series evening shade
we got this far somehow
you can believe somehow
october is a month that's been
associated with the walking dead for
many years now but in 2018 it brought
unwelcome news for fans of the show just
one day before the ninth season premiere
on october 7th actor scott wilson passed
away after a battle with cancer the
actor who portrayed farmer herschel
green between 2011 and 2014 was 76.
wilson was a lead cast member in seasons
three and four and he became a popular
figure among the cast and crew his
passing was announced on the walking
dead's official twitter account our
thoughts are with his family and friends
rest in paradise scott we love you in an
official statement amc said that
herschel was always at the emotional
core of the walking dead and that he
continues to inform our character's
choices to this day long after his death
if you're from northeastern america
you'll probably recognize the late james
caron's face even if you never knew his
name until now the character actor will
be forever remembered as the pathmark
man because of an advertising campaign
for pathmark supermarkets that lasted
almost two decades so come to pathmark
come to number one 24 hours a day for
value and savings overall
karen actually lived in los angeles
miles away from the nearest pathmark
store he passed away at the age of 94 in
his la home the pennsylvania native also
popped up in hundreds of hollywood
movies over the years including return
of the living dead and 1982's
poltergeist good buddy george clooney
claims karen once tricked him into
writing his obituary prematurely saying
he just wanted to know what everybody
thought about him while he was still
around he got a bunch of people to do it
emma chambers the british actress known
for the romantic comedy notting hill
died february 21st at the age of 53.
according to the bbc she died of natural
causes this is one of those key moments
in life
and it's possible you can be really
genuinely cool and i
i'm going to fail just a hundred percent
her breakthrough came in 1994 when she
starred in the bbc miniseries based on
charles dickens's martin chuzzlewit she
also played village church verger alice
tinker on the popular bbc comedy the
vicar of dibley appearing in all 20
episodes of the show through 2007
american audiences probably remember her
best as honey the eccentric younger
sister of hugh grant's character in
1999's notting hill she also played
helen yardley on the tv series how do
you want me from 1998 to 1999.
stan lee became such a beloved figure
not only with comics fans but among
everyone in general with his
down-to-earth style and folky mannerisms
we all knew he wasn't in great health
but still in november 2018 when his own
epic arc came to an end at the age of 95
we were all crushed born in 1922 lee's
first gig at the age of 17 was as a
gopher at timely publications comic
books were far from mainstream at the
time but the success of superman over dc
comics gave owner martin goodman hope he
tasked lee with writing a story for
captain america number three and within
the span of two years the youngster had
become editor-in-chief at timely later
known as marvel comics from his
cluttered office in manhattan lee helps
create numerous classic comic book
characters and superhero teams from
spider-man and black panther to the
fantastic four and of course the
avengers lee famously made short but
sweet cameo appearances in marvel movies
with his personal favorite being the
time thor got him blind drunk in
avengers age of ultron
he told playboy in 2014 keep moving
forward and if it's time to go it's time
nothing lasts forever
it's difficult to overstate just how
much hollywood owes to penny marshall
who died on december 17th at the age of
75 due to complications from diabetes
her status as a legend would have been
cemented if she'd only been known for
being one half of the popular tv duo
laverne and shirley but that was only
the beginning as her impact on
television and film went much much
further she became a true trailblazer
for women in show business when she
directed the tom hanks star making
vehicle big which was the first female
directed film to gross more than 100
million dollars and just a few years
later she directed a league of their own
which the library of congress selected
for preservation in the national film
registry in 2012 for its cultural
significance
sadly these aren't the only actors who
left us in 2018. here's a look at some
of the many stars who enhanced our lives
before leaving us all too soon jerry van
dyke
reg e kathy
john mahoney
david ogden steyers
stephen hawking
duchamp monique brown
donnelly rhodes
connie sawyer
mark sawling
robert dowdle
john gavin
debbie lee carrington
dorothy malone
vic dimon harry anderson
r lee ermey
mickey jones
nanette fabre
susan anspatch
joseph campanella
robert manden
eunice gayson
stanley anderson
tab hunter
elmery wendell
mary carlisle
charlotte ray
stefan carl stephenson
robin leach
barbara harris
clint walker
vanessa marquez
susan brown
carol shelley
bradford dilman
doreen tracy
christopher kennedy lawford
bill daley
peter benson
derek o'connor
gloria jean
allen anne mcleary
peter donat
al matthews
james jimmy karen
diana soule
yvonne sewer
marin mazzee
jackson odell
ricky j
peter masterson
frank adonis
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk that number again is
1-800-273-8255
before their deaths the following actors
didn't just make their marks as some of
marvel's most popular or interesting
characters they left behind impressive
bodies of work with hollywood being all
the better for their contributions these
stars weren't just marvel favorites they
built some of hollywood's most
distinguished careers
miguel ferreira comes from a major show
business family his cousin was superstar
george clooney and his parents were
oscar winner jose ferreira and 50s pop
star rosemary clooney david lynch fans
remember ferrer as the opinionated fbi
agent albert rosenfield on twin peaks
ferrer also co-starred in the 1994
adaptation of stephen king's the stand
playing randall flag's right-hand man
lloyd henry apart from his dozens of
other tv guest star roles ferreira made
memorable appearances in films including
traffic hotshots part do and robocop but
observant marvel cinematic universe fans
will remember him for his brief but
important part in iron man 3. in the
final entry of the trilogy ferrer played
rodriguez the corrupt mandarin connected
vice president of the united states who
tries to help assassinate president
matthew ellis sadly in january 2017
ferrer died of cancer-related
complications at the age of 61.
when stand-up comedy boomed in the 1980s
and early 1990s tons of clubs popped up
in cities cable networks filled out
their programming day with shows like an
evening at the improv and the hbo comedy
half hour and a ton of joke tellers
became instantly famous among them was
jon pinette a gifted stand-up and
impressionist panette dedicated a lot of
his act to making fun of himself he
toured and taped comedy specials
extensively while also landing acting
roles after playing a high school coach
on parker lewis can't lose he appeared
on seinfeld dr katz professional
therapist and in 2004 he showed up as
bumpo in the ultra-violent film
adaptation of the ultra-violent revenge
comic the punisher opposite thomas jane
pinette brought comic relief to the
otherwise dark movie as the easy-going
character and the financial beneficiary
of the punisher's crusade tragically in
2014 pinette was found dead in a
pittsburgh hotel room and a medical
examiner ruled that he'd passed as a
result of natural causes pinette was
only 50.
in 1969 peter fonda produced and starred
in the hippie and counterculture classic
biker movie easy rider for which he
received his first of two academy award
nominations the second came for 1997's
yuli's gold in which fonda starred as a
grieving beekeeper with a troubled
family in between fonda appeared in
dozens of well-known movies including
the last movie the cannonball run and
escape from la fonda's role in ghost
rider as mephistopheles was among the
last in a long legendary career
in 2007 actor and avid comic book fan
nick cage got his superhero franchise
going with two ghost rider movies cage
played johnny blaze a bounty hunter
forced into service for the unholy demon
played by fonda in 2019 fonda passed
away at age 79 due to lung cancer
just before 2010 irfan khan got acting
gigs in popular and acclaimed american
and british films he played a police
detective in the oscar-nominated slumdog
millionaire and he portrayed the adult
version of main character pai patel
recalling his survival of a shipwreck in
the oscar-nominated life of pi khan
showed up as dinosaur park owner simon
masrani in jurassic world and he also
played the villainous provost in inferno
fans of andrew garfield's peter parker
will also recognize khan from the
amazing spider-man where he played oz
corp executive and scientist dr rajeet
ratha as a prolific television actor
khan broke through to the a-list of
indian cinema in the 2000s and won
numerous accolades for his work in life
in a metro hasil and pon singh tamar
which won him a national film award for
best actor shockingly in 2018 khan
announced that he'd been diagnosed with
a neuroendocrine tumor following a
hospitalization in mumbai for an
infection in 2020 the superstar died at
age 53.
in 2008 iron man became the first marvel
cinematic universe entry but the modern
history of movies based on marvel comics
characters goes back to 1986 with the
critically reviled box office flop
howard the duck protagonist howard is
involved in everything sci-fi including
the cosmos itself personified and voiced
by veteran actor richard kiley
the cosmos
countless whirls upon worlds
kylie was a decorated actor appearing in
shows like hawaii 5-0 and colombo and
won four emmy awards and two tony awards
including one for man of la mancha kylie
died in march 1999 of a blood disorder
he was 76 years old
as one of film and tv's most prolific
intense and versatile character actors
it's hard to say exactly which role is
the one for which reggie kathy is best
known it might be warden martin kearns
on the harrowing prison drama oz or
political organizer norman wilson on the
wire or barbecue joint proprietor
freddie hayes on house of cards which
won kathy an emmy award for outstanding
guest actor in a drama series kathy also
played more than one role in multiple
marvel franchises in the 2015 fantastic
four reboot he portrayed dr franklin
storm father of superheroes sue and
johnny storm kathy also starred in
netflix marvel cinematic universe
adjacent series luke cage in the role of
james lucas a pastor and the father of
luke in february 2018 kathy died at his
new york city home from lung cancer
according to the new york times kathy
was 59
dr wesley von spears appeared briefly in
both guardians of the galaxy films he
didn't have any lines but he was
memorable just the same because von
spears is a dog in guardians of the
galaxy the pup portrayed holographic dog
and in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 he
played the part of dog in the back of
truck at dairy queen landing a role in
hollywood is sometimes about who you
know and nepotism definitely played a
part in von spears casting since he was
the pet of guardian's writer director
james gunn the dog's influence on marvel
movies comprises more than just a couple
of cameos gunn told io9 truthfully a lot
of groot is based on my dog von spears i
think there's a sort of puppy-like
innocence to groot that if my dog could
talk it would probably say i am groot dr
wesley von spears died at age 17 in
february 2020. gunn briefly delayed
filming on his next film the suicide
squad to fly home and be with his dog in
his final moments
bernie mac tweed trang sage stallone
these actors and more were sadly all
taken from us too soon keep watching to
find out which actors you may not have
realized had died
one of the original kings of comedy next
to cedric the entertainer dl hughley and
steve harvey bernie mac built his hugely
successful career through a stand-up
routine heavily influenced by richard
pryor that in and of itself isn't
unusual but mack used that cornerstone
to build a presence and style that was
uniquely his own i never watch what
somebody else does
it does not matter
bernie mac got to do his thing
that hard work paid off in hollywood
with a series of high profile roles many
might recognize mack as ice cube's
neighbor pastor clever in the movie
friday he'd go on to star in charlie's
angels full throttle ocean's 11
transformers and more and also headlined
a sitcom loosely based on his own
experiences called the bernie mac show
during the last years of his life max
suffered from sarcoidosis which heavily
affected his lungs and he succumbed to
pneumonia complications on august 9 2008
at the age of 50.
harold remus was 69 when he passed away
from an autoimmune disease in 2014 which
in and of itself might have come as a
surprise to many of the film fans who
watched him in 80s classics like stripes
national lampoon's vacation and
ghostbusters a talented director and
screenwriter as well as a frequent
fixture in some of the biggest comedy
hits of the decade reimus behind the
scenes talents helped bring us groundhog
day and caddyshack among many others in
fact he jumped back and forth between
either side of the cameras throughout
his career co-writing both of the
ghostbusters movies as well as stripes
although few fans knew he was ill remus
struggled with the side effects of his
infection for years he had to learn how
to walk all over again after contracting
autoimmune inflammatory vasculitis in
2010 and suffered a relapse the
following year
his final on-screen appearance came in
the 2009 comedy year one
a veteran of stage and screen who
amassed a distinguished career spanning
decades richard harris notched arguably
his highest profile role late in his
career courtesy of the blockbuster harry
potter film franchise
in two of his final screen appearances
harris played potter's beloved
headmaster albus dumbledore in the first
two installments of the blockbuster film
franchise the sorcerer's stone and the
chamber of secrets
although he'll always be dumbledore to
generations of potter loving fans
outside of hogwarts harris compiled
multiple careers worth of impressive
credits and honors
he was an accomplished singer actor
director writer producer and songwriter
who won grammy and golden globe awards
for his work on 15 different albums and
more than 70 films including camelot the
guns of navarone gulliver's travels
patriot games unforgiven gladiator and
the count of monte cristo after being
diagnosed with hodgkin's disease harris
died on october 25 2002 at the age of
72.
best known for playing the young carol
anne from the movie poltergeist heather
o'rourke skyrocketed to instant fame as
the sweet young girl that terrified
audiences after being sucked into the
television set in fact she may have
played the part a little too well
although o'rourke racked up an
impressive list of credits after her
breakthrough performances carol and she
remained tied to the franchise in the
public's mind and she was one of a very
small number of original cast members
that remained with the movie series
until its conclusion with 1988's
poltergeist 3. if you've seen the final
movie you may notice that heather's
cheeks appear very puffy and although
audiences didn't know it at the time it
was a reaction to the medication she was
taking for crohn's disease with which
she was misdiagnosed
tragedy struck on february 1st 1988 when
heather suffered from cardiac arrest
while undergoing a surgery for a bowel
obstruction at the tender age of 12. tui
trang was best known for her work as the
original yellow ranger on mighty morphin
power rangers but unlike a lot of actors
who start out in genre tv she seemed in
no danger of being typecast in fact she
was developing what seemed like a
potentially promising career after
leaving the show trang jumped right into
feature work landing roles in a pair of
movies released in 1996 the dark drama
the crow city of angels and the leslie
nielsen comedy spy hard clearly trang
had enough chops to tackle work from a
variety of genres but sadly she never
had a chance to fulfill that potential
she was killed in a car accident at the
age of 27 in 2001 after the driver lost
control of the vehicle and it plunged
over a guardrail on california's
interstate 5. emergency medical
personnel tried getting trang to the
hospital but she died in transit the
result of massive internal injuries
one of hollywood's all-time ultimate
that guy actors taylor negron compiled a
truly compressive list of classic screen
credits without ever becoming a
household name although he tended to be
on screen for no more than a few moments
at a time negron's deadpan delivery made
him a fan favorite among film
aficionados of the 80s and a stand out
in pictures like fast times at richmond
high and better off dead
later in his career negron made
memorable appearances on hit tv shows
like seinfeld and friends but as much
fun as he could be on screen he was even
more interesting behind the scenes in
addition to acting negron was an
acclaimed writer whose work included
published collections of short stories
as well as a trained painter whose work
was shown in multiple galleries he was
only 57 when he died in early 2015 after
a battle with liver cancer
after making a name for himself as a
professional wrestler rowdy roddy piper
branched out onto the big screen most
notably through his starring role in the
1988 cult classic they live leading that
cult john carpenter classic piper waged
war against a covert alien invasion and
coined an unforgettable catchphrase i
have come here to chew bubble gum and
kick ass
and i'm all out above them
piper's bone-crunching work in that film
helped set the tone for a busy hollywood
career full of b-movie roles and small
but unforgettable appearances on
television shows like it's always sunny
in philadelphia on the screen as well as
in the ring piper gave every performance
his all frequently elevating otherwise
forgettable material and consistently
serving as the most memorable component
of whatever project he was appearing in
he died in his sleep in 2015 after
suffering a pulmonary embolism that
triggered a heart attack
critically maligned and pretty much
ignored at the box office rocky 5 is
indisputably the least loved film of
sylvester stallone's long-running boxing
franchise take a careful look under its
cheesier elements however and you can
see the outline of a truly affecting
story about a former heavyweight champ
going broke losing his ability to box
and nearly losing his relationship with
his son to help tell the story stallone
brought in his own fourteen-year-old son
sage to play the part of robert rockey
jr balboa in the film and young
stallone's time on the set clearly made
a positive impression after college sage
continued working in the industry in
small low-key projects carving out a
career in his own right apart from his
blockbuster leading father unfortunately
sage died on july 13 2012 at the young
age of 36 due to a heart attack brought
on by coronary artery disease
long before he founded an ill-fated
amusement park using the secrets of dino
dna richard attenborough was already an
accomplished and award-winning actor
attenborough starred alongside steve
mcqueen in the great escape released in
the midst of a busy period that included
some of his most widely seen work he
also won two consecutive golden globe
awards in 1967 and 1968 for co-starring
in the sand pebbles and dr doolittle
needless to say attenborough's career
contains no shortage of highlights and
his work will no doubt be familiar to
classic film fans younger film goers
however have their own attenborough
memories thanks to his appearance as
john hammond whose ambitions led to the
creation of jurassic park that
blockbuster made him famous to a whole
new generation but it's just one short
chapter in a life of many great
cinematic achievements that ended on
august 24th 2014 at the age of 90.
would you talk about willis
kids of the 70s and 80s and honestly
anyone who enjoys the classic sitcoms of
the era will immediately recognize the
immortal catchphrase gary coleman coined
as an adorable kid on the long-running
hit sitcom different strokes coleman's
diminutive stature helped him continue
to play younger characters throughout
much of his career and at the peak of
his fame he landed a series of film and
television roles unfortunately his
youthful looks and peak height of 4 feet
8 inches were side effects of an
autoimmune kidney disease combined with
the medications he took throughout his
life to fight the condition
work in hollywood became harder to come
by after strokes left the airwaves and
behind the scenes he underwent frequent
dialysis treatments and was forced to
undergo two kidney transplants
after a fall at his home coleman died on
may 28 2010 of an epidural hematoma at
the age of 42.
exactly where you remember esteemed
actor edward herrmann from depends on
whether you favor musicals vampire
movies medical tv shows or fast-talking
mother-daughter family dramas
hermann is probably best recognized
today for his role as pompous but
warm-hearted patriarch richard gilmore
in the series gilmore girls richard's
dry sense of humor and quiet authority
contrasted with the quick wit and
constant banter that flew between his
daughter lorelei and his granddaughter
rory and his wife emily who was played
by kelly bishop offscreen hermann and
bishop both classically trained and
meticulous about their craft were
especially close herman's wife starr
whom he married in 1994 would joke that
bishop was his other wife
in hermann's final moments his family
invited bishop to say goodbye with them
before his longest running role in
gilmore girls hermann worked regularly
on tv and in movies he was nominated for
an emmy for playing a priest in the
medical drama saint elsewhere and won
one for the legal series the practice
he played franklin d roosevelt in the
1982 adaptation of annie having
previously played the president for a
mini-series and tv movie in the late 70s
and in 1987 he played a stepfather from
literal hell in the vampire movie the
lost boys
hermann died of brain cancer at age 71
on december 31 2014
in the netflix revival of gilmore girls
it was revealed that richard had also
died sparking big changes for emily in
particular
deezer dee was one of the foundational
actors on hit medical trauma er
born darren thompson he played nurse
malik mcgrath on the show's entire
15-year run appearing in 188 episodes as
often happens in real hospitals as well
as fictional ones er typically focused
on its physicians and surgeons not the
nurses but thompson was one of just a
handful of actors who appeared in every
season and his episode count makes him
the fifth most prolific member of the
large cast
outside of er thompson had a few small
parts in movies including the cult
classic comedy romy and michelle's high
school reunion and appeared in vanilla
ice's video for cool as ice
he played one of the members of a
fictional rap group in the mockumentary
movie cb4 in 1993 and also rapped for
real he released multiple records
including the full full-length album
delayed but not denied in 2008 and
continued making songs until his death
his final track history can't be stopped
was released posthumously thompson
started having heart issues around 2008
telling radar online the following year
that he had been suffering from
recurrent pneumonia and heart failure it
was discovered that he had a leaking
valve and expanded aorta which was
addressed with surgery in 2009
according to deadline he went on to have
more operations on his heart over the
next 10 years or so thompson died on
january 7 2021 at the age of 55 of a
suspected heart attack
catherine justin was in her 50s when she
started working consistently and
notoriously youth-centric hollywood in
the mid-1990s
she'd start acting in 1980 after
realizing she was missing out on
following her dreams despite her late
start geoustin built a career playing
one-off but always memorable characters
in hit tv series her credits include er
third rock from the sun seinfeld
roseanne the nanny frazier buffy the
vampire slayer and the x-files to name
just a few later she would add the likes
of will and grace and grey's anatomy to
that list in short name a hit show of
the 90s and 2000s and justin probably
appeared in it her most memorable guest
appearance was as a woman who refused
treatment for kidney failure in season 1
of scrubs the episode my old lady
consistently ranks as a fan favorite
thanks in no small part to justin's
performance
unfortunately we don't really have a
choice
actually i do have a choice
certain things you never expect to come
out of a person's mouth
i think i'm ready to die
in addition to those guest roles justin
landed regular parts in two major series
she played the steely secretary to
martin sheen's president bartlett in two
seasons of the west wing combining her
talents for fast-paced drama and comedy
and nosy but occasionally helpful
neighbor karen mccluskey and desperate
housewives houston was first treated for
lung cancer in 2001 the year mild lady
aired she was undergoing treatment while
making the final season of desperate
housewives which was written into her
character's arc mccluskey died in the
season finale juicedon died two weeks
after that episode aired on june 2nd
2012 at the age of 72.
hugh dane's resume reads like a list of
the top sitcoms of the 90s and early
2000s he played two different characters
in the fresh prince of bel air appeared
in an episode of martin and multiple
episodes of rock he had small parts and
friends sister sister everybody hates
chris and new girl on the drama side he
played a judge in an episode of the west
wing he also appeared briefly in the
comedy movies little [ __ ] and
bridesmaids however dane will most
likely be remembered and missed for his
role as hank the permanently unimpressed
security guard in the office he appeared
in 22 episodes of nbc's hit mockumentary
about the inner workings and ridiculous
shenanigans in a scranton pennsylvania
paper company
dane died at the age of 75 on may 16
2018
after his death his the office co-star
rayne wilson described him as one of the
greats so kind funny and talented on
january 1st 2021 nbc's streaming
platform peacock tweeted a video of a
cold open that never aired dedicated to
dane it showed one of jim's most
elaborate pranks on nemesis dwight
featuring dane as morpheus from the
matrix
if the blue pill is not safe to swallow
someone should tell us now
kenny baker originated one of the most
beloved characters in one of the most
popular movie franchises of all time but
you wouldn't recognize him from that
role out of costume baker is most famous
for playing r2d2 the brave and
mischievous star wars droid he was born
with dwarfism but it wasn't just baker's
height that made him perfect for the
roll according to his new york times
obituary he was the only person small
enough to fit into the costume who was
also strong enough to move it
it helped that baker had been in
entertainment for years he sang danced
played instruments clowned and ice
skated in various touring companies
as he told the guardian there are
certain close-up movements only i can do
convincingly it's all about giving r2 a
personality and cgi can never really do
that in addition to r2 baker played an
ewok in return of the jedi alongside his
wife and fellow actor eileen but the
furry violent inhabitants of the jungle
planet endor were less fun to play than
to watch thanks to the stuffy costumes
it wasn't just that they were hot the
heads were impossible to see out of when
they steamed up
the last time baker played r2 was for
revenge of the sith although he served
as a consultant on the force awakens he
also appeared in many other movies and
series including flash gordon time
bandits and amadeus he died at the age
of 81 on august 13 2016.
if you're a millennial who grew up
wishing you could have an identical twin
to swap lives with you probably remember
natasha richardson best for her role as
the extremely cool fashion designer mom
in the lindsey lohan lead remake of the
parent trap that was richardson's most
prominent screen role but she had a
prestigious stage career
it started with a touring version of the
seagull which ended in london's west end
with richardson appearing opposite her
mother renowned british actor vanessa
redgrave tv fans may know vanessa best
for her role as dr erica naughton in
niptuck opposite her older daughter and
natasha's sister jolie richardson
jolie should also be known to fans from
the parent trap era as anita in the 1996
live-action adaptation of 101 dalmatians
as you've probably noted natasha was
part of an acting dynasty her
grandfather sir michael redgrave
vanessa's father was famous for
tragedies natasha's aunt lynn redgrave
vanessa's sister was an oscar-nominated
theater superstar to round out the
family lin and vanessa's brother coryn
redgrave was a stage actor and
playwright natasha met actor liam neeson
when they starred opposite each other in
a broadway production of anna christie
she was nominated for a tony for the
role and the two later married and had
two sons together
natasha died suddenly of head injury
sustained during a skiing trip on march
18 2009 she was 45.
in a show that made superstars out of
its six main cast members james michael
tyler managed to hold his own as one of
the most memorable side characters he
played coffee shop manager gunther and
friends for all 10 seasons appearing in
150 episodes total although he didn't
have a line for his first 33 appearances
tyler originally landed the role because
he knew how to work the fancy espresso
machine on the central perk set not one
to take himself overly seriously after
friends he played himself in the satire
episodes which saw that version of tyler
experiencing a slightly awkward reunion
with matt leblanc who played joey on
friends also playing himself tyler loved
the experience of being in friends
although there was one drawback as he
told digital spy he was cast with very
distinctive bleached blonde hair which
added to his character's mystique but it
was originally the result of an
experiment he let one of his friends
perform which turned into weekly bleach
jobs for 10 years
tyler was diagnosed with prostate cancer
in 2018 which he didn't make public
until june of 2021.
that month he announced in an interview
with nbc that the cancer had reached
stage four meaning it had spread to
other parts of his body he died just a
few months later on october 24 2021
a veteran stage film and television
actor richard griffiths is known by the
masses for his portrayal of harry
potter's uncle vernon dursley while
dursley was for the most part always
cruel to the young wizard he was still a
part of harry's family and he ultimately
helped prove that the boy who lived had
a golden heart because he still cared
for the uncle who treated him poorly
outside of the harry potter series
griffiths won a slew of awards over the
course of a busy career earning
particular acclaim for his portrayal of
english teacher douglas hector in a play
called the history boys
he also starred in a variety of projects
including superman 2 gandhi sleepy
hollow king ralph hugo pirates of the
caribbean on stranger tides and the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
griffiths passed away at 65 on march 28
2013 due to complications shortly after
having heart surgery
brad renfrow skyrocketed to fame at age
11 through his acclaimed work in joel
schumacher's adaptation of author john
grisham's book the client high profile
roles quickly followed and renfro made
appearances in sleepers opposite brad
pitt the informers starring kim basinger
and ghost world alongside scarlett
johansson yet as his star continued to
rise on screen renfro faced a darker
path behind the scenes one that would
ultimately see him fulfilling the sad
destiny of many child actors plunging
into a life of illegal drug use and
trouble with the law after attempting to
buy drugs from an undercover la police
officer renfro pleaded no contest to
attempted possession of heroin and spent
10 days in jail on january 15 2008 at 25
years old renfro's turbulent story
reached a tragic end when he was found
dead of an accidental heroin and
morphine overdose in his apartment in
los angeles
dana plato played kimberly drummond in
the long-running hit television series
different strokes cast alongside fellow
child stars gary coleman and todd
bridges she was catapulted to instant
stardom
to cope with the mounting pressures of
fame plato often indulged in cocaine and
marijuana off the set yet it wasn't
until she became pregnant that the
network released her from her contract
helping her trigger a downward spiral of
drugs and alcohol that included work in
adult films and a spread in playboy
magazine
she later moved to las vegas where
desperate for cash she robbed a store
for less than 200 and was bonded out of
jail by vegas entertainer wayne newton
she died at the age of 34 on may 8 1999
in her rv in oklahoma after taking a
fatal dose of lortab and valium
best known for her work starring as mel
gibson's daughter in the blockbuster the
patriot skye mccoll bartusiak was a
child actress with a promising future
she made her film debut in the cider
house rules in 1999 and starred with
michael douglas and brittany murphy in
don't say a word in 2001. she also
appeared in the film kill your darlings
with true blood star alexander skarsgard
in 2006.
unfortunately bartusiak's life behind
the scenes wasn't as glamorous as fans
might have assumed and included some
dangerous drug habits that would end up
contributing to her having an accidental
overdose in 2014. according to
bartusiak's mother the young star had
also been suffering from epileptic
seizures prior to her passing which led
to the family initially believing she
choked to death before the coroner's
ruling made the tragic truth clear
before getting his big break michael k
williams was consistently cast as
one-dimensional criminals he was a young
black man in a white industry that
didn't know how to tell diverse stories
about people who looked like him also he
had a distinctive facial scar from the
time someone attacked him with a razor
something else hollywood didn't know
what to do with
william's big break came courtesy of the
wire character omar little an armed
robber who targets drug dealers and the
most feared man in a territory ruled by
violence but little wasn't a carbon copy
of those previous characters for one
thing he was openly gay in a homophobic
society that mocked gay men as weak for
another he was known to give some of his
ill-gotten gains to people in his
much-in-need community
after playing omar williams landed roles
in several prestigious series including
crime drama the night of when we rise
about the gay civil rights movement and
a recurring part as a racketeer in
prohibition drama boardwalk empire he
even got to show off his comedy skills
and community in 2019 he appeared in ava
duvernay's when they see us as the
father of one of the wrongfully accused
central park five
in 2020 he was nominated for his fifth
emmy for the hbo series lovecraft
country
williams died at the age of 54 on
september 6 2021 of what was later
confirmed as a drug overdose
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the substance abuse and mental
health services administration website
or contact samhsa's national helpline at
1-800-662-help
some of the most talented performers of
all time reached the end of the road
doing what they loved making movies and
television for devoted viewers across
the globe their sudden passing while on
the job left their castmates reeling and
fans heartbroken
here are a few stars both young and old
whose lives were cut short while they
were hard at work
red fox on his classic 70s sitcom
sanford and son red fox was famous for
faking a heart attack to get out of a
conversation an audiences loved it
this is a big one
i'm dying
hear that elizabeth
i'm coming to join you honey fox brought
the bid out of retirement when he
returned to tv in 1991 with a sitcom
called the royal family but during
rehearsal according to production
spokeswoman rachel mcallister fox and
his co-stars were clowning around and
red was sort of breaking people up when
he collapsed they all thought he was
joking at first four hours later at the
hospital fox passed away at age 68 of a
heart attack john eric hexham
26 year old heartthrob john eric hexsom
starred in cover-up a cbs action show in
which he played an elite military
operative one day in october 1984 the
producers told hexam that scheduling
issues would delay filming so he grabbed
a prop gun and quipped can you believe
this crap
then he pulled the trigger prop master
frank lowe remembered he unloaded all
but i guess won one round what would
appear to be a game of russian roulette
put it up to his head and pulled the
trigger the prop gun fired a cotton wad
bullet driving a bone fragment into his
brain which caused severe hemorrhaging
the actor was rushed to the hospital
where he fell into a coma and passed
away six days later
john ritter
while he had a successful film career
with roles in slingblade and bad santa
john ritter will forever rank among our
most beloved and prolific tv actors
she's gonna send you bowling i don't
know
i'm supposed to teach you
[Music]
his likability and gift for physical
comedy helped elevate three's company
and his return to tv in 2002 as the star
of eight simple rules for dating my
teenage daughter was one of the biggest
stories of the year abc had renewed the
sitcom for a second season and
production was underway in september
2003 when ritter suddenly fell ill on
set feeling dizzy and nauseated while
complaining of chest pains ritter
checked into a hospital in burbank where
doctors treated him for what they
initially thought was a heart attack but
further tests revealed a previously
undiagnosed aortic dissection which
proved fatal for ritter he was just 54
years old
steve irwin famously known as the
crocodile hunter steve irwin was the
enthusiastic australian nature show host
who boldly ventured into hostile
environments to teach viewers about
dangerous and exotic creatures you can
see why they call them tiger
tiger rattlesnakes but in september 2006
as erwin and crew were filming a
documentary about the great barrier reef
in australia irwin and cameraman justin
lyons encountered an eight-foot wide
stingray which attacked irwin lyons said
the creature launched hundreds of
strikes in a few seconds delivering a
fatal dose of venom and a two inch wide
gash over irwin's heart he was 44 years
old tommy cooper a beloved british
entertainer tommy cooper combined corny
jokes prop comedy and magic for an act
that was popular in the uk for decades
but tragedy struck in april 1984 when
cooper appeared on the live from her
majesty's variety show the show's host
jimmy tarbuck and likely many viewers of
the live broadcast
thought cooper was improvising when he
fell to the ground but the entertainer
had suffered a heart attack the show cut
to commercial and cooper was rushed to a
hospital where he passed away at age 63
tyrone power
having enjoyed a meteoric rise to
superstardom in the 1930s tyrone power's
breakthrough role in lloyd's of london
came in 1936 when he was just 22 years
old he went on to establish himself as
an extremely versatile actor but was
most often cast in swashbuckling
adventure movies such as the mask of
zorro in 1958 power landed a title role
in solomon and sheba but on november 11
1958 as power shot the eighth take of a
demanding sword fighting scene he
started to shake and said he suddenly
felt chilly and achy power passed away
on route to the hospital having suffered
a fatal heart attack at age 44.
star wars has been around for decades so
it's a sad but inevitable reality that
many of the actors who have appeared in
that galaxy far far away are no longer
with us here are a few faces from the
franchise you may not have realized
passed away
admiral ackbar had a pretty small role
in the original star wars trilogy in
fact he only appeared briefly in return
of the jedi even still the character's
appearance made him a firm fan favorite
as did the iconic line that is now
passed into pop culture legends
naturally then fans of star wars mourned
the unfortunate passing of akbar's voice
actor eric bowersfeld who died in 2016
at the age of 93. interestingly
bowersfeld once argued that he thought
of his movie roles as a secondary career
that he had accidentally stumbled into
as opposed to his more solid work as a
radio producer he once wrote the voice
work i did in movies was accidental i
was working with randy tom on radio
dramas at his technical quarters at
lucasfilm one day ben bert sound
designer for star wars came by and asked
if i would audition for a voice in the
movie bowersfeld also voiced bib fortuna
one of jabba the hutt's associates and
he returned to the role of admiral akbar
in the force awakens which released just
months before he passed away
as he dies in the opening hour of the
film uncle owen can be considered a
pretty minor star wars character in the
grand scheme of things but his death is
the primary call to arms that sets luke
skywalker off often his hero's journey
so in a weird way owen is actually one
of the movie's most important characters
making actor phil brown one of the
story's pivotal players sadly brown
passed away in 2006 at the age of 89.
even though he was well known when star
wars was made he'd faced plenty of
hardships as an actor in the 1950s brown
was caught up in senator joseph
mccarthy's communist trials and was
actually blacklisted because he refused
to comply with the house on american
activities committee's demand to name
communists in hollywood he denied being
a communist himself but was still forced
to move to london to continue acting as
it happened george lucas was filming in
london at the same time and needed a
local actor with an american accent so
he brought brown on board not long after
brown was with lucas in tunisia filming
a new hope's early scenes on tatooine
a powerhouse english actress sheila
frazier died in 2000 at the age of 79.
she had played a small but memorable
role in a new hope as luke's aunt beru
the character dies early on in the story
so frazier was unable to contribute a
lot to the film but just like lars
beru's death spars luke into action
driving his character arc through much
of the trilogy and even though her role
in star wars is small some would argue
that she's indirectly responsible for
luke becoming the hero he is at a new
york comic-con panel author meg cabot
argued that very case suggesting that
aunt beru's kindness and caring for luke
helped him overcome the dark side and
defeat the empire it also helped him
find the compassion to look for the good
left in darth vader without whom he
never would have stopped emperor
palpatine so yeah nice work aunt peru
drew henley appeared in the star wars
franchise as red leader the pilot who
led luke's squadron in the strike
against the death star at the climax of
a new hope sadly he was accidentally
credited as drew hemley at the end of
the film but hey he at least managed to
squeeze in a post-mortem appearance in
rogue one thanks to the power of archive
footage in the first film red leader
actually nearly destroys the death star
he launches his torpedoes at the exhaust
port but his aim is slightly off not
long after his miss his ship is
destroyed and the poor guy is
subsequently killed henley was a
well-respected actor when he was cast in
a new hope but was forced to retire not
long after the film was released due to
his struggles with bipolar disorder
after working through his mental illness
he settled down to run a bed and
breakfast with his wife henley died in
2016 at the age of 75.
anakin skywalker has been played by
multiple actors across the star wars
franchise but when his deformed weary
face is revealed in star wars return of
the jedi that's classically trained
actor sebastian shaw playing the role he
also portrayed anakin's force ghost at
the end of the original version of
return of the jedi before being replaced
by hayden christensen in subsequent
releases shaw was mostly known as a
stage actor outside of star wars fandom
he was a member of the royal shakespeare
company where he'd often play lead or
featured roles he was also a broadway
veteran and was well known for taking on
parts in daring and controversial plays
lucas choosing to digitally replace shaw
with christensen in return of the jedi
sparked some controversy at the time but
star wars fans will still never forget
the reveal of darth vader's face shaw
passed away in 1994 at the age of 89.
jason wingreen didn't actually appear in
the star wars films in person but his
voice brought one of the saga's most
iconic villains to life wingreen was the
original voice of boba fett the
intergalactic bounty hunter who tracks
down han solo during the empire strikes
back wynn green was also a well-known
television actor when he auditioned for
star wars having appeared in a number of
different shows throughout the 60s 70s
and 80s he originally auditioned for the
role of yoda but lost out on the roll
and was cast as boba fett stead and only
recorded four lines for the final film
he's not even credited and it wasn't
until the year 2000 that the public
discovered who had voiced the villain
still it's a testament to wing green's
talent that boba fett became such a
massively popular character nonetheless
when green passed away in 2016 at the
age of 95.
you may never have seen kenny baker's
face or heard his voice in a star wars
film but it's a fair bet you still know
who he is for most of the movies in the
franchise he portrayed one of scifi's
most iconic characters r2d2 r2d2 wasn't
a puppet or an animatronic like so many
other creatures in the star wars
universe instead there was an actor
inside that droid baker was only three
foot eight inches so he could fit inside
the chassis used for filming and he's
the one responsible for crafting much of
r2d2's personality when baker passed
away in 2016 at the age of 81
starwars.com wrote whether it was the
slow turn of artu's dome to convey
suspicion or nervous wobble signifying
fear baker made a robotic being seem
very human while baker played the droid
in all three original films and two
prequels he also played an ewok in
return of the jedi
peter cushing was a massive star when he
was cast as grand moff tarkin in a new
hope he also brought an immediate
gravitas to the film losing menace and
calm and somehow coming off every bit as
intimidating as darth vader himself
charming to the last
before appearing in a new hope cushing
was an icon in horror cinema he appeared
in many of the dracula and frankenstein
films of the 50s and 60s and also
portrayed sherlock holmes in a few movie
adaptations after a long and illustrious
career cushing passed away in 1994 at
the age of 81. despite this however he
technically reprised his role as tarkin
in rogue one a star wars story even
though the film came out over 20 years
after his death cushing was recreated in
the film with state of the art cgi
nearly climbing out of the uncanny
valley in the process nearly
even though obi-wan kenobi died in a new
hope alec guinness appeared in the other
films of the original trilogy thanks to
the power of the force his casting lend
some credibility to the original film
but he also infamously viewed the story
as in his words fairy tale rubbish
guinness was a hugely famous actor when
he signed on for george lucas's space
opera he'd won an oscar for the bridge
on the river kwai and had starred in
classics such as lawrence of arabia and
dr zhivalgo and while many of the
leading actors in star wars are big
names now they weren't at the time
making guinness by far the biggest star
in the movie in 1977 but why did he join
the project if he hated the material
well there are a couple of reasons first
he thought the moral of the story was
admirable enough second he wouldn't have
to do any publicity for the film and
third the studio offered him a massive
salary of course he ignored any fan mail
he received about star wars and hated
discussing his role as obi-wan sir alec
guinness passed away in the year 2000 at
the age of 86.
one of the most prolific actors in the
star wars franchise christopher lee's
career spans over 250 roles over the
length of his career lee is absolutely
one of the gods of geekdom and has
graced several of hollywood's most
notable franchises here he portrayed
count dooku in two of the prequel films
attack of the clones and revenge of the
sith lee became a star due to his many
appearances in the hammer horror dracula
franchise where funnily enough he
frequently collaborated with another
star wars alum peter cushing lee's
imposing figure in commanding voice made
him perfectly suited to play the villain
which helped him a great deal and
arguably his biggest ever film role
playing saruman in the lord of the rings
a man of many talents christopher lee
also released a number of heavy metal
albums when he was in his 80s and 90s he
was also knighted served in the second
world war as a member of the raf and was
attached to the british army's
long-range desert group the precursor of
the modern day sas he passed away in
2015 at the age of 93.
despite never having shown his face on
screen in star wars peter mayhew quickly
became one of the saga's most iconic
characters his performance as chewbacca
helped bring a sense of real humanity to
a character where many other actors
could have easily been lost beneath a
mask
laugh it up fuzzball
mayhew was a hospital orderly when he
auditioned for chewbacca and even kept
that job until after return of the jedi
was released the seven foot three inch
actor then essentially made his living
off the roll for the rest of his life
attending conventions as a fan favorite
star for decades he eventually reprised
the role in 2015's the force awakens
nearly everyone who worked with mayhew
on the star wars franchise had nothing
but kind things to say about him after
his death in april 2019 mark hamill
wrote on twitter he was the gentlest of
giants a big man with an even bigger
heart who never failed to make me smile
and a loyal friend who i loved dearly
i'm grateful for the memories we shared
and i'm a better man for just having
known him
[Music]
you